christoph metzelder hat gestanden sagt
uns noch einmal was genau ist da gerade
passiert wie ich das ganze abgelaufen
vor allem was bedeutet das jetzt für
diesen prozess des jahres
ja ich würde sagen jetzt erst mal ein
stall geständnis abgelegt er hat gesagt
dass er im internet screenshots gemacht
habe von frei zugänglichen seiten bei
den bildern um die es dort geht wundert
mich das ehrlich gesagt dass das frei
zugänglich gewesen sondern sollte man
muss das jetzt aber erst mal sehen was
die staatsanwaltschaft dazu sagt er hat
aber eingeräumt dass trotz gemacht hat
von solchen bildern
er sprach davon sei um extrem fantasien
in chats gegangen dabei sei es auch um
das unaussprechliche gegangen hat das
bewusst selber gar nicht ausgesprochen
er sprach von inkriminierten bildern wie
er dabei gemacht hätte und diese bilder
auch verschickt hatte er betont habe er
sei nie in foren gewesen von
einschlägigen pädophilen er sein hier im
bett gewesen er habe diese dinge auch
nicht heruntergeladen und er hätte sie
auch nach dem versenden immer wieder
sofort gelöscht
er stellte es darauf ab dass es eben und
fantasien gegangen seien um
ursprüngliche fantasien um ganz
besondere sexuelle fantasien und hätte
dann sich eben hinreißen das sind diese
bilder zu verschicken um das ganze auch
ein wenig als doch harmloser einzuordnen
auf der anderen seite muss ich sagen das
habe ich ihm auch ehrlich abgenommen er
hat bei dem geständnis ich möchte mal
zitieren damit ich nichts falsches sei
ja davon gesprochen dass er moralische
schwere schuld auf sich geladen hatte
und das ja auch eine wunde verursacht
hätte die möglicherweise nie wieder
verheilt und er sagte dann auch noch er
möchte sich stellvertretend bei allen
menschen und allen kindern insbesondere
die opfer sexualisierter gewalt oder
sexueller gewalt geworden sind
stellvertretend entschuldigen weil er
wisse welches unsägliche leid hinter
jedem dieser fotos stecken würde
und was er sich nicht verzeihen könnte
dass er das gewusst habe und es trotzdem
getan hätte und während dieses
geständnisses stockte immer wieder seine
stimme einen moment hatte ich wirklich
das gefühl dass er beginnt zu weinen und
auch nicht weitersprechen kann und das
schien mir schon wirklich sehr ehrlich
zu sein weil er auch weiß dass er sein
eigenes leben damit komplett zerstört
hat und das kam schon das war der erste
moment wo man das ehrliche gefühl hat
dass ihm etwas nahe geht ehrlich gesagt
aber ein bisschen auch das gefühl es
ging eigentlich nur nahe dass er sein
eigenes leben zerstört hat
er hat sich häufig gesagt stellvertreter
allen kindern entschuldigt die opfer
geworden sind
aber es wirkt auch ein wenig
vorgeschrieben trotzdem muss man sagen
er steht wenigstens dazu
er hat das alles eingeräumt konkret die
vorwürfe die einzelnen bilder und das
noch nicht aber wie gesagt dieses tages
stellen ist grundsätzliche geständnis
liegt jetzt vor
die richterin hatte vorher gesagt dass
sie es gab keine förmliche einigung
zwischen staatsanwaltschaft verteidigung
und richterin aber die richterin hätte
in aussicht gestellt in diesem
rechtsgespräch eben warum wir so lange
ja auch warten mussten dass sie bei
einem geständnis von zehn bis zwölf
monaten auf bewährung ausgehen würde die
sie dann als urteil in den raum gestellt
hat auch mit zelda und dem verteidiger
gesagt wenn sie weiterhin ein geständnis
ablegen auch wenn es keine förmliche
einigung jetzt gab weil die
staatsanwaltschaft das nicht wollte
fühle ich mich trotzdem ein stück weit
daran gebunden dass ich in einem
ähnlichen strafhöhe ein urteil fällen
wäre das heißt wir können jetzt mal
davon ausgehen ist wir reden hier
vermutlich von ungefähr einem jahr haft
auf bewährung und die bewegung auch wohl
ohne auflagen das hatte man mal überlegt
dass vielleicht noch eine hohe
geldzahlungen als auflage geben könnte
aber das scheint jetzt momentan in die
richtung zu gehen wie gesagt zehn bis
zwölf monate auf bewährung
trotzdem geben jetzt weiter in die
beweisaufnahme wir haben jetzt gerade
den saal wieder verlassen müssen weil
jetzt die jets im einzelnen erläutert
werden natürlich auch im sinne der
verteidigung habe es vorhin schon mal
gesagt in diesem chat soll es noch mal
um extreme sexuelle fantasien auch mit
kindern gehen dafür sind wir aber
ausgeschlossen worden natürlich auch zum
schutz der kinder weil auch die fotos
jetzt besprochen und gezeigt werden
und dafür so lange ist die
öffentlichkeit ausgeschlossen frank ich
hab natürlich gleich ganz viele fragen
an die ich die erste du hast gesagt
dieses geständnis das war einerseits
authentisch er hat da gestockt auf der
anderen seite wirkte es auch ein
bisschen wie vorgeschrieben mich würde
interessieren aus deinem gefühl hat
christoph metzelder dieses geständnis
diese worte heute schon in der
tasche gehabt und auf einem zettel
mitgebracht oder ist das etwas was in
diesen zwei stunden der unterbrechung
dann sozusagen entstanden entwickelt ist
entwickelt wurde und er dann so von sich
gegeben hat nein ich bin felsenfest
davon überzeugt dass er das genauso
mitgebracht hat das ihm aber natürlich
während dieses teilgeständnis klar wurde
auch noch mal persönlich klar wurde was
das ja auch für ihn bedeutet auch dieser
tag hier auch diese diese öffentlichkeit
die jetzt hergestellt ist mit diesen
vorwürfen
er war natürlich dabei als diese anklage
verlesen und er weiß ja am besten das
auf diesen bildern zu sehen war und ihm
war auch klar dass das leben danach für
ihn nie wieder so sein wird wie vor
er sprach aber eben auch davon dass eine
wunde an gericht hätte auch für andere
ich vermute er meint damit auch seine
familie in die vielleicht nie wieder
heilen würde und das merkte man das geht
ihm sehr nahe
aber man muss auch leider ehrlich sagen
es ging mir auch nahe weil es auch ein
stück selbstmitleid war sein leben ist
zerstört
und das ist eben genau der entscheidende
punkt aber das hat er sich eben selbst
zuzuschreiben er versuchte das eben wie
gesagt noch mal ein wenig zu
verharmlosen er habe keine tiefe
pädophile neigung
er hätte sich auch in therapie begeben
er ließ sie sich helfen er würde das
alles aufarbeiten
aber es wurde immer so ein bisschen
dargestellt er sei so eine art moment
sexueller fantasie etwas abgerückt aber
wie gesagt wenn wir die bilder die
vorhin in der anlage genannt wurden
kennen jetzt jedenfalls in der
beschreibung kennen dann ist das mir ein
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen zu lapidar
und zu einfach als entschuldigung zu
sagen da waren irgendwelche sexuellen
fantasien
ich glaube keiner von uns kann sich
vorstellen sexuelle fantasien zu haben
wo kinder missbraucht und auch schwester
vergewaltigt werden was das jetzt in
einer beziehung auch in einer eigenartig
erotischen fantasien und einer
unbekannten frau die er da ist ein
zweimal getroffen hat und eine rolle
spielen soll erschließt sich mir nicht
eine begutachtung hat meiner
wahrnehmung hier auch nicht
stattgefunden soll auch nicht
stattfinden wie gesagt er hat sich
selbständig in therapie begeben das geht
seit einem jahr
und da muss man natürlich kann man ihm
jetzt auch nur wünschen dass er
vielleicht auch sich darüber klar wird
was er da möglicherweise angerichtet er
hat auch noch mal betont er habe nie nie
auch nur ehrlich darüber nach also
überhaupt in erwägung gezogen diese
übergriffe von denen er fantasiert hätte
wirklich auszuleben
er hätte auch nie übergriffe der plan
ist daher auch nicht zu übergriffen
gekommen aber das hat ja noch mal
ausdrücklich betont nach dem motto es
war immer noch fanta sie ist war nur
verschickte bilder in einem virtuellen
raum
aber ich habe nie so etwas in meinem
wirklichen leben geplant gemacht oder
auch nur beabsichtigt frank tun hast du
gesagt und für uns zusammen gefasst da
ist also heute die anklage verlesen
worden
da ist nun dieses geständnis verlesen
glaubst du denn auch dass wir dann heute
schon mit einem urteil rechnen können in
dem fall oder wird die richterin das
weiter so durchziehen wie das
ursprünglich geplant war mit drei
prozesstagen das muss man jetzt abwarten
sie hat ebenfalls einen zeugen der
gerade gehört werden sollte hat sie
gerade schon wieder nach hause gehen
brauchte sie jetzt nicht sie hat auch im
sogenannten selbst leseverfahren wir
sind natürlich heute schon durch diese
über zwei stunden unterbrechung ein
bisschen im zeitplan natürlich
verrutscht das sicher steuerungs
protokoll der beschlagnahme der
durchsuchung hat sie in sogenannten
selbst leseverfahren das heißt man kennt
ja die aktenlage die verteidigung kennt
die staatsanwaltschaft kennt die
richterin auch dann liest man noch mal
eben quer und dann muss das nicht nur
alles verlesen werden weil das auffällt
und jetzt ist man in der beweisaufnahme
was die chats anbetrifft und auch was
die bilder an betrifft ich gehe nicht
davon aus dass heute noch ein urteil
fällt insbesondere weil in dieser
verständigung die staatsanwaltschaft
auch klar gesagt hat sie will in die
beweisaufnahme
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass wir heute
schon ein urteil hören